le petit théâtre de nevers a rouvert ses
portes huit ans de fermeture pour
vétusté 3do travaux l'équipement cherono
versoix sort d'une période chaotique le
rouge fyk les dorures sont très très
belle aussi bas on attendait oui je
pense que tous les ans nous versons
attendaient impatiemment cette cet
événement ont maintenant qu'on est
rouvert qu'on va pouvoir profiter des
spectacles
et puis les coulisses comme j'ai envie
de dire eh bah écoutez c'est les
coulisses ça ne regarde pas si le
chantier est terminé le feuilleton de la
direction du théâtre s'est prolongé
début 2018 la gestion est attribué à
coline serreau préféré un un projet
local
mais rebondissement en juillet alors que
la réalisatrice de trois hommes et un
couffin doit prendre ses fonctions
elle ne donne plus signe de vie avant
que la municipalité ne revienne sur sa
délégation pour raisons de procédure
coline serreau a tourné la page et donc
nous l'avons tourné aussi voilà donc on
va décrit une autre à partir
d'aujourd'hui c'est comme ça il ya eu un
choix sa part été le bon contact
ce qu'il faut surtout regarder devant
plutôt que le passé c'est comme cela a
donc finalement ça peut être un mal pour
un bien est ce théâtre va connaître une
belle saison et sans doute encore plus
dense que ce que ce que cela aurait été
avec une délégation de service public le
dossier cristallise les divergences
politiques de la propre adjointe à la
culture jusqu'à l'opposition qui dénonce
l'opacité des méthodes
le maire et son équipe ont réussi
incontestablement la réouverture du
petit théâtre
après je pense que malheureusement ils
ont échoué sur l'aspect de la politique
culturelle qui a eu très clairement un
marché truqué très clairement
ne sert on n'aurait pas dû être retenu
dans le cadre de cette délégation de
service public
très clairement elle a fait défaut on
l'avait dit dès le départ que sa
candidature n'était pas valable
c'est dommage parce que je pense que ça
a cassé une dynamique la gestion directe
par la ville est pour le moment prévu
pour plusieurs saisons
place maintenant à la nouvelle
programmation qui démarrera en octobre
en espérant que le théâtre symbole de
division politique redevienne un lieu de
rassemblement pour tous les noeuds vers
soi
[Applaudissements]